Some 13.8 billion years ago,
a very hot,
smaller,
dense singularity expanded into what we now call the universe.
It hasn't stopped growing since,
but what if it did?
What if all the galaxies,
stars,
planets,
everything stopped moving away from everything else with the universe as it is
just freeze or would it collapse into a single point just like it was before the
Big Bang and would that be the end of everything?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the universe stopped expanding before the 1920s
when Edwin Hubble observed that the galaxies moved away from each other.
We thought the universe was static.
Years later,
the Hubble Space Telescope showed us that not only is the universe expanding,
but it's growing at an ever increasing rate.
This came as a total surprise for astrophysicists.
They expected that the expansion was actually slowing down due to the force of
gravity to explain the discovery.
They theorized that there's a force speeding up the expansion of the universe.
They called it dark energy.
What if this hypothesized energy suddenly stopped,
stopped pulling the universe apart?
Let's assume the strength of dark energy diminished over time,
but was still enough to counteract the force of gravity.
What would that look like?
If that were the case,
the universe would become just like Albert Einstein imagined it 100 years ago.
Before Hubble's discovery changed the game and I'd signs viewpoint,
it would be static.
The universe would neither be expanding nor contracting.
Eventually,
stars would exhaust all the gas needed for their formation.
Fewer new stars would be born and the existing ones with burnout,
the universe would grow darker packed with black holes.
By that time,
the earth would be long gone,
absorbed by a red giant star.
They used to be our son.
At some point it would reach its eventual temperature,
minimum absolute zero or zero k on the Celsius side.
That's minus 273 degrees.
At that temperature,
Adam's themselves would stop moving.
The universe will become absolutely lifeless,
but let's go back and assume that dark energy became so weak that it couldn't
counteract the force of gravity anymore.
Once the gravity took over,
it would pull everything back.
The universe would start contracting.
Galaxies would draw closer together until they merge into one mega galaxy with
the stars melting into each other.
Space would become hotter than the sun,
and again,
packed with black holes.
The result of exploding stars,
these black holes would suck up everything around them.
Planets,
stars,
entire galaxies,
even one another.
Eventually they'd form one monsters,
black hole that would pull the entire universe into a single point,
hot,
small,
and extremely dense.
The universe would end in a big crunch reverting back into what it looked like
at the start,
and who knows.
The newly formed singularity might explode into another big bag,
creating a brand new universe with new stars,
new planets,
and new life farts.
We don't know exactly how our universe,
universal land,
we don't even understand what the dark energy pulling it apart is.
That's why there's not just one theory explaining the ultimate fate of the
universe.
There are several good ones.
Any one of them might be correct,
but they could be wrong altogether.
Join us next time on what if.